Doc Rivers is at midcourt right now how  many brothers Austin Rivers no that's  the best look at the Sun saying call him  for a team tee up my dad he's on the  other team in there it is  [Applause]  [Music]  that might be sPB's best thing that he's  seen all night  DOX son begging for his dad to get a  technical and now waiting for him oh  good who's that Austin just looked at us  he's like get him out of here get him  out Andy bought him dinner last night  that should hold some sway so doc got a  jacket Austin's like call me dead  calming  what doesn't matter  when  there's a victory at stake here but what  was the big argument about that's what I  want to know like like what timeout  discrepancy